hello and welcome to live coding with
Jessie alright today we're not gonna do
a whole lot of new coding we're gonna
check out some some pull requests
because the pool requests are adding up
and I've been really busy so I haven't
really had a chance to review them so
today we're gonna review them I figure
this would be cool to do live we've got
a little bit of this before but some
some of you maybe have never been in a
position to review a pool request or try
to work on merging them so I'm gonna try
to do the whole process here on the
stream this is gonna have to be a
shorter stream so we're gonna go maybe
about an hour long at most and it's
early because I have meetings later on
so I can't I can't stream my normal time
so well I have one meeting that's going
to be really long this afternoon and I'm
gonna go get a haircut in about an hour
and a half so I didn't realize that I
had the other meeting in the afternoon
until this morning otherwise I would
have given you a heads up yesterday
about the early stream
alright so hey everybody I see some of
you are here yeah hopefully the
notifications worked for you all so
let's get started let me share my screen
and I'm just going to go through some of
the new stuff before we get to the pull
requests I just want to show you all the
JavaScript
AF website so yesterday I let you all
know that I am now the owner of
JavaScript on AF so I'm not sure exactly
what I want to do with it
long term but her should had an idea to
make a like a discord server so her
should set up a discourse server or
digitalocean and so right now javascript
RAF is pointed here so if you have any
questions that we don't address in the
live chat or maybe you'd like to have
some ongoing discussion you can join go
to JavaScript AF and join and it's
basically like a forum like an online
forum so that's there for now I'm
thinking if I decide to do something
else with JavaScript on AF then I can
always move this to a subdomain and so
we can keep it going but for right now I
think this is a pretty cool thing to do
and it will at least be useful I just
wanted whatever we did with it to be
useful so I think this this will be
useful I know we have several other
channels like we have a slack channel
and we had something with like oh I
think we have like three different
things going on right now in terms of
being able to chat so this is adding
another thing but it's central location
anybody can join so hopefully this will
be you know it's not exactly that a chat
room like slack is but hopefully it'll
be useful so check that out javascript
dot AF and if you have any other ideas
for what I should do with that domain
let me know like I said we can always do
we can always just move this to a
subdomain if we want to do something
else with the main domain
alright it looks like the notification
didn't work for some of you it's because
I scheduled the stream so late and I'm
I'm sorry about that if I schedule it
less than an hour before I'm actually
going to stream then it seems like
notifications don't work so we'll switch
it
oh yeah Harsha said that server is still
on harshest insulation partially we can
get it switched over to mine I don't
want you to have to pay for that for
that server so I actually have credit on
digitalocean that I need to use up
anyway it's going to expire I think in
April so we'll get that switched over
let me think I don't know what all the
info you need to switch it but it's I
think the account my main account the
email is just Jessie Weigel at gmail.com
let me know what other info you need to
transfer that and then I'll just I'll
take care of I don't know how much
credit I have but it's it's cool I'll
just take care of the cost of it ok cool
her shoots gonna send me the snapshot
then then all I'll take over but thank
you for setting that up our shoot it was
that was really fast setup - alright so
we've had a lot going on in in the pool
requests and different things on a lot
of different projects so we're gonna
we're gonna catch up with things now so
just to give you a little overview so
we've been working on mainly these three
projects so actually there's four
projects that we've had progress on but
I told you all about the electron app
yesterday and I showed you so we have
the Resource Center as an electron hat
and I still want to do a little bit more
testing with it especially on on a
Windows machine and make sure everything
works right but so far on a Mac
everything is perfect so
so I just lost my train of thought I got
a slack message and it derailed me
that's the only way the the Resource
Center is taken care of I really want to
get a repo up for the bulletin to turn
that into an electron app but we
actually haven't finished the bulletin
the react version of it so we were harsh
it was doing some work on it so hard
[ __ ] I had asked about implementing a
Microsoft login so you knew course you
all can follow along with this on github
if you want all these repos Republic
make it bigger so you can see so I had
asked about using a Microsoft login for
the bulletin since the university I
worked for switched over to office 365
about a month ago so I thought hey let's
try that and I specifically asked
hardship for help because he had set up
the password 'less login system that we
currently have running on this project
so he went ahead and just set it up and
I tested it unfortunately the problem is
when you have like I work Microsoft
account it doesn't automatically become
a Microsoft account it doesn't I don't
have that makes sense but like if I
tried to log in to like Outlook calm or
if I tried to use Microsoft to
authenticate into something else and I
put in my work email it would say that
account doesn't exist so there are some
other steps we can take to make it work
but I think a simpler solution and one
that will be more user friendly is that
we're just going to check so we're going
to keep the password this login and only
allow logins from Franciscan GDU
addresses and we're also going to accept
any user that is coming from our single
sign-on page
because if they're there at that page it
means that they've already signed into
that page so we can trust that you know
they've got there and if they got here
there are somehow some other way I'm not
worried about it really then we have
bigger problems just somebody reading
the bulletin so we're just going to use
document dot refer which is just in
JavaScript and it lets us get the URL of
whatever site the user was on last
before they came to this site you know
whatever say it linked from so that's
what we're gonna do still need to
implement that I'm actually working on
implementing that on the current version
which is just a jQuery single page app
that is a private repo right now I I
don't know maybe I'll make it a public
repo at some point but it's really kind
of a mess of jQuery and custom routing
with that it's using the WordPress REST
API so I don't know for right now it's
gonna stay private but I'm gonna try to
implement the referrer thing I was doing
that yesterday and then I got I had to
go to a meeting and I couldn't finish it
so it will be tested out before we even
launched this react version of it so
that's it for the react Billiton and
well maybe I'll put a note and enclose
this but I want to leave a note as to
why we're closing that so we just have
some basic stuff so Franciscan react
this is the main Franciscan ddu website
that we're working on and you have a
bunch of stuff let's check on some of
these issues first and then we'll get to
this pull request so if you don't know
why I am on github these are just my
notifications so you wouldn't be able to
see this page because these are
notifications for all of my repositories
you'd have to go to these repositories
individually but material UI has gone to
beta 30 so yeah it is our she mentions
they're updating it quite a lot they are
for sure I just noticed that on Twitter
yesterday at some point and yeah it's
crazy we're updating material ID very
frequently which is fine it's cool as
long as there's not a lot of breaking
changes just have to have to check for
that so right now this is just an issue
if anybody wants to try to update and
then double check the things are still
working you know feel free to do that
otherwise I'll get to it you know at
some point in the near future but thanks
our [ __ ] for for bringing that up in an
issue I would I wanted to but it's
possible I may have forgotten to do it
anyway alright so I created this issue
well 13 days ago and we wanted to add a
search bar to the top map on that
Franciscan site so
Nikki took a shot at this and let's
check out what's going on let me make
sure that this isn't what that pool
request was no it's not okay all right
so let's take it [ __ ] take a look at
what's going on here and see if we can
sort this out I see there's there's a
lot more activity here in the in the
live chat I'm gonna get to that in just
just a few minutes
all right so I'll read this out in case
you can't read this if the quality is
bad or if you're just listening since I
got stuck trying to implement this one
everything would find until I wanted to
add the open/close animation I added an
is search open boolean to the state and
wanted to change the value assigned to
the search field class based based on
that that boolean got flipped on the
search icon clicked something like with
okay changing the width with the
transition all right
the function with the style rules is not
inside the component so you can't access
the state like that there I'm attempting
to add this animation wrong way how
should I go about it all right I guess
don't you what the style rules is not
inside the component okay so the problem
is the style rules what if if you can't
change the style rules because of the
function there what if you just added a
class to the the element and that
changed it like a class like open or
closed and then you set instead of
having the class be search field you can
have a class that's open and a class
that's closed then you should be able to
access state and it'll switch back and
forth between the two if if anyone else
has another way to do that let me know
otherwise I'm going to type this in
mr. States
okay let me okay
comment on that and see and this one is
we're gonna change color of the search
field underlined alright so we had in
the sidebar we have another search field
and the color was some like neon green
color that didn't match our palette so
alright it looks like so Nikki had asked
about the color but then when I had I
think it implemented no maybe not
or maybe I just already checked it out
yeah it is there's an open for requests
alright so change color search label
winning port focus
all right let's check so this is a good
pool request here so the pull request is
directly referring to one of the issues
that I open and it's it's short it's
focused it explains clearly what's
changed including code samples even as a
suggestion for potentially improving it
now usually when I go to check a pool
request on github I read this first and
then I go to the the files changed and
then I see what has actually changed so
we can see really dealing this change is
just a two additional classes with some
CSS and it looks like yeah so we
actually have the classes here now yes
we've added the classes so those are all
the changes when the changes are very
small like this and the effect is
obvious I don't bother to actually pull
in the changes on a separate branch and
test it so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna merge the pool request right here
and I like I said I only merge like this
if the changes are small and very
obvious what they do so I don't
recommend merging like this without
testing unless you're absolutely sure of
what's going on a very minor CSS change
like this is fine but especially if
somebody's bringing in like other NPM
packages and doing things like test it
first on a separate branch
I always like to write a thank you
message if you maintain something I'd
recommend like always writing a thank
you message it only takes a second and I
think it's polite I like to get
thank-you messages all right great so we
have one full request merged and let's
check this one out and also this one so
this one is add links in the drawer so
we have that side drawer let me see I
should probably bring the site up let me
get this site running so that we can all
see man and I just showed my dot end
file on on YouTube live so I'm
definitely gonna have to change that now
we weren't gonna end up we're gonna take
out that functionality anyway so I can't
believe I just did that
let's see looking for my there it is
okay I need to get into I'm gonna cancel
this and grot I'm not even sure what was
on there
and let's start up this Franciscan site
all right wonderful so let's bring this
here we are so this is what we're
talking about this sidebar and with our
links we wanted to have some leg
external links under here so that's what
this pull request is talking about and
since we did merge something in on
github it's a good idea to pull in those
changes
let me find area Franciscan site let's
move this over and
have a change in the yarn file no all
right
I think yeah that's it it's just the
yarn the unlock
all right
all right so I'm pulling the changes
that we just had but it's working once
we had emerged since I had a change in
the lock file that I did not commit
and it it opened automatically an atom
on my other screen
it's close
all right great so that works
okay great so now everything is up to
date and I've already showed this so
many times let me just I may as well
show this we're gonna have to change all
of this stuff which is fine because
those are all testing things anyway
I know I already accidentally showed it
so that's why I just left it on anyway
that way anybody is trying to take my
API keys save you time from having to
try to pause it and right at the right
second alright I'm worried that right no
no anyway here's what I wanted to show
so here's what we have with the color
change we see I said that's not bad I
was thinking of using like this yellow
color that we're using for this button
but it's not too bad with the gold color
especially since it's right up against
this what do you what do you everybody
think about this let me turn on an grukk
so you all can contest it out as well
all right we're almost coming up to
about the halfway point the stream so
I'm gonna take a little break and go
back to the live chat now but I do want
to did want to get that end grukk server
up and running so if you can click on
the link in the live chat now you'll be
able to check out the site stellt let me
know what you think about the color of
the search bar do you think it should be
the yellow color that we have on the the
buttons in the that are over top the
hero image do you think it should be a
different color in the color palette
like maybe the grain let me know I'm
open to anything all right
and yeah so let me go to the live chat
now I'm gonna answer some questions and
then we'll come back and we'll try to
pull in the rest of our pull request
handle any merge conflicts we have so we
may end up having some conflicts here
which I was I was kind of hoping that we
had conflicts just to show that process
so awesome so we will have some here
it's it's only gonna be just within one
of the components which shouldn't be too
difficult but at least we'll get to see
the process we can actually maybe we'll
try to resolve conflicts here I don't
think we've ever tried to do it right in
github on the stream before we have done
it through the command line but let's
try to do it and github so that's what
we'll work on next see Siberian says a F
stands for Afghanistan or what yes a F
does stand for Afghanistan so you know
there's the country domains so I think
every I believe every country has their
own domain I'm not sure that I mean
countries that are really new newly
foreign may not have it but yeah dot AF
is for Afghanistan so I actually had to
like go on and fill out some information
an Afghanistan like government website
which it was kind of odd
Candice Gander 7 says forum equals
old-school
yeah forums are kind of old school but I
mean there's they're useful they still
work
ah let's see Aleksey says Jessie can you
order your videos and playlists by each
project yeah I definitely can I know
I've been talking about it for a while I
just haven't gotten around to do it for
every project I think I do have it done
for some projects maybe like project one
and two and at least one of the projects
I think I did I just need to get around
to doing it for the other project so
sorry about that
that's one of those those things that's
been on my mind for a while it's just
easy to put off you know
satya says digitalocean change the
pricing it's cheaper now yeah yeah
that's true so if you use digitalocean
check it out i'm sure you've got an
email about it but the pricing
structures change so you get more
powerful droplets for the same amount of
money that you've been paying which is
awesome and if you haven't tried out
digitalocean now you know might be a
good time to check it out because the
prices are better now John John Hanson
says that site it's not written in react
needs a better logo with a winking face
yeah maybe we should write a react site
for that since we're always working with
with react Harshit said we'll change it
with Jessie's face haha no you don't
have to put my face on it's the logo I
hope those a joke oh I gotta check is it
really gonna be my face on here I don't
know where it went
I thought I brought it over to show it
but I guess I moved it back over all
here it is it's on my other screen oh no
it's not work you know I guess maybe
arch is doing something on it
let's see Harshit says document.referrer
can't be trusted as someone can map that
single sign-on link to their host file
and can refer to your bulletin I I know
the document dot refer is not secure
right
my goal is a very like moderate level of
security for the bulletin so let me let
me give you some background to explain
the bulletin used to be a word document
that was emailed out to everyone and
then what happened is everyone would
just email that out to whoever else
wanted it so their spouses or anybody
else in the community people who didn't
even work here or on the email list and
got the bulletin when I early on when I
got here one of my first tasks was
redoing the bulletin to make it a
website or at least make it it was very
vague it we just needed to make it you
know more more interactive updated a bit
so my guidelines were my idea was well
there doesn't there's no reason we
really need to make a password because
there's not really any sensitive
information in the bulletin and if we
did have sensitive information we
usually send separate special emails
with like important in the tagline so I
didn't think we'd need it but then we
basically I had to so I was told I had
to make it password-protected but there
couldn't be any new passwords so that's
why I came up I mean it's not like I
invented pass for this login but that's
why I decided on password this login
right so I'm not worried it's not like
we're guarding some some secrets here
essentially we just need to have some
semblance of this being somewhat
protected
just to let you know like the level that
we're at here is that there are other
documents that are supposed to be like
password-protected and literally it is
just one password that everybody in the
whole University just has the same
password so like you log in to an area
and it's just in plain text on the page
here's the password to get to this place
so we're not like anyway well I would it
be nice to have it be secure like that
but to be honest with you the next time
that I have a meeting about it which
should be on Thursday morning I'm gonna
really try to get it so that we don't
even need a password at all because I I
don't think it's necessary and I know I
mentioned this before but like 95% of
the emails and phone calls and visits
that I get where people are having
problems with things that I built are
all about the password this login system
for the bulletin because there are
various things older browsers don't work
some people will clear out their local
storage or they have some sort of new
program that clears out their local
storage so things it's always the
problem so anyway my plan is to just not
have any password protection at all on
this thing if possible if I can't do
that then my backup plan is just to use
this referrer thing that was actually
what IT recommended to me to do when I
asked them about integrating this with
their single sign-on system they said do
the refer thing my response was that's
not really secure just like harsh it was
saying but the more I thought about it
more I thought well what's really the
big deal
my other plan is we're gonna turn the
bulletin into a desktop app and a mobile
app at some point just like we're doing
with the Resource Center so potentially
I could have that only available for
people to download from behind
to login so if you have that you'll just
get access and then if other people want
to share that file to download I mean
that's that's out of my hands at that
point but it'll basically be the same
level of security we had back when it
was a Word document being email so let
me know what you think about that if
anybody thinks I'm crazy or there's some
other way to do this but that's kind of
the situation that I have gone on with
with that particular project
sorry ego says we'll just see early by
the way hello hey ebo yeah i'm really
early I just have my normal during my
normal stream time well what has become
the normal which is 12 p.m. my time I
have a haircut
I made the appointment like before I
started streaming at that time so that
was unintentional that it would overlap
with a stream and then I have another
meeting in the afternoon that's supposed
to be a long meeting
and see
david says remember Jesse triumphant
pride precipitates a dizzying fall I
think I think this is the third time
that David has typed that and as always
that is definitely true and good advice
so thank you although usually I hear
that same phrase quoted as pride goeth
before the fall either way same meaning
so anyway basically try to stay humble
stay humble that's good advice let's see
Gander seven said when we were talking
about what was the issue it was with all
with that toggle that search toggle the
issue about how to get that animation to
happen Gander seven says couldn't you
pass the open closed status as a prop
well essentially the the problem at some
point you want it to be instincts you
get a rerender right so I guess if it's
as long as it exists in the state and
some component it could be pressed down
as a prop but I think either way the way
that I said will work the way that you
said could probably work as well
let's see John Henson says the state for
class can be a string that toggles okay
Dacron says what does the end : after
thing do I'm a noob and rook said it
changes the color of the bar underneath
the search bar yeah yeah that's
basically what it does Rick says like
the blue color underneath the bar when
you type a comment here in the YouTube
chat doctrine says el hello all the API
keys yeah yeah all the API keys look
says oh the those changes are in the
same file as the previous full requests
or the conflicts now dacron says I think
it would not offer to merge now if
they're conflicts what we'll just you
have to deal with the conflicts no life
says hi can you tell me what's wrong
with my tribute page of code pen do you
do such things no life send me send me
the link oh here it is
let's check this uh
I let's check this tribute page out real
quick so you want to know what's wrong
with your tribute page I don't remember
what all the user stories are for this
particular free code camp thing so it
looks okay to me I mean you have a time
line you have an image title I mean like
in terms of fulfilling user stories I
think this is fine in case you're
wondering this is one of the free code
camp exercises that you have to do is I
think this one's pretty early on so yeah
I don't yeah I think it's fun let me
know if anybody else wants to to check
that out and give some feedback in the
live chat you know please feel free
Harshit says discord theme should I
switch the light theme the dark theme
seems too dark I don't know I kind of
like the dark theme you know me though I
like all the dark themed stuff but if
you all like the light theme keep it
light I can always just run like a
custom script to change it dark you know
or even maybe they'll have the option to
do that I don't know I haven't checked
out all the settings yet
and see
Eva Sisters tests take a while yeah the
test sometimes take a lot for a minor
change like we had when we were running
it it does take a while but I mean
that's it's okay tests are good to have
so I'm willing to go through it
sometimes they're faster than other Suns
even if there's a field of social media
icons are a bit too heavy on the eyes
and the top right of the screen maybe
spaced them out a little more alright
let's check it out we're talking about
these social icons yeah maybe we can
adjust it but yeah there needs to be
some adjustment here I think because we
need to pull this button down off the
top you know we don't we want to add a
little padding up here and we could kind
of play around with different different
spaces between these I'd like them to be
kind of have like a minimum size so that
they're still clickable like reasonably
clickable but we can kind of mess around
with this and see what what works and
also I had a thought I don't know why I
didn't think about this earlier like I
mean look at what we have right now on a
small screen it looks terrible like
really terrible we've basically been
ignoring the mobile view when what we
should have been going all along is
working on the mobile view primarily and
then occasionally expanding out to make
sure it still works all right all right
if we think about this this website is
targeted at teenagers or is a teenager
more likely to view this on their phone
or just sit down at a desktop or laptop
computer and view this I mean I I can
look up the statistics but if I had to
bet I'd say that a teenager is more
likely to be on the
their phone so we should do is as we
continue to develop this we should do
all development like this and then the
desktop view should be secondary to this
view I don't know what do y'all think
about that I used to do all my
development like that and I don't know
why I got away from it probably because
I worked on some internal projects where
it was going to be over overwhelmingly
viewed on a desktop and I just got used
to that but for this project I think it
really makes sense to do the the mobile
view first so that's what I'm gonna
start doing so in future streams this
will be the default
Aleksey says I like the golden color but
not the yellow of the buttons eyesore
talkin here alright so the golden color
is good but that yellow color not good
okay thank you for the feedback I
appreciate that okay I just saw ours its
message that Harsha was upgrading to
discourse divergent version two so it
might not might be unavailable so that's
that's why it was unavailable briefly
for me Devin says every tech startup
uses dot IO and that's Indian Ocean
domain yeah yeah you could so the dot
eight using dot AF for something other
than a website in Afghanistan is not
it's not uncommon for people to use
country code domains for other things
right and I'm sure we've all been to a
dot IO web site because it seems like
every tech website now is dot IO like we
were on code pen right now it's code
pentaiah
gander seven says if you click a menu
option like academics click the grade
Jumbotron and click the same menu item
again it opens the sidebar with the
submenu close yes excuse me I am aware
of that issue and I did come up with a
solution for it I just did not code it
yet
so I don't know what happened but I
remember I was about to put to implement
that and then I got pulled into
something else so I needed to do that
but thank you thank you for bringing
that up and I'm really glad you reminded
me because I've completely forgotten
about it John Henson says I like the
look of the search when clicked awesome
awesome cool
I will probably like right now this
isn't centered so I want to make sure
that that centered but other than that I
mean that that's pretty much good to go
Dacron says have you ever considered
starting your own group on the side to
take small take on small projects with
volunteer developers I finished a boot
camp recently I've been trying to
improve hard time finding projects
that's a good idea
oh yeah I want to talk about that more
let me know in the live chat what you
all think so let me know number one
would anybody be interested in something
like that and if we were to do something
like that how would it work would we do
like free projects for nonprofits would
we want to do paid projects yeah how
would I mean I guess if we did that it
to be almost like we were an agency but
so I think it would be a lot easier to
take on free projects because we
wouldn't have to deal with all like the
taxes and paperwork and stuff but let me
know what you all think I'm I'm not
entirely opposed to the idea I mean I
guess it could operate a lot like we do
now we could potentially have like live
coding sessions so that everybody can be
there checking it out explaining it and
then have different people coding things
and then we could maintain our
repositories on github
all right let me know what you all think
though I do think that's kind of a cool
idea and I actually already have a
project in mind I don't I have one
organization that could potentially be
interested and it could eventually turn
into something that we we would either
sell or we could just keep it open
source and make it available I guess let
me know I guess I can just tell you what
it is I don't care if anybody else tries
it and if I think it's something that
needs to be made by somebody
doesn't have to be me but I I see a very
big need for a learning management
system that's open source that's
reliable and fits all the criteria to be
able to be actually used by schools you
know there's a lot of there are stricter
data rules about students especially
students like under 18 at least in the
United States so whatever we would do in
terms of you know collecting data having
a database we need to make sure that
that's all in shape to be able you know
to meet whatever standards it needs to
but basically I wanted to be a more
modern like full-stack JavaScript build
it out with react I want it to be very
fast I want it to be able to be have a
UI for web mobile and desktop and so the
user can use it wherever they feel most
comfortable it definitely obviously
needs to work Mobile on one so there are
a lot of parts of the world where people
only have access to a phone and not a
desktop and their internet is not great
so it needs to be a progressive web app
that works well on a phone so I would
say it needs to be like mobile first so
like we designed the whole LMS to be
able to work on a phone and then when
you expand it to a desktop it basically
just gives you more space we might be
able to display more things but we do it
always with a phone in mind and always
in mind that the user doesn't have a
good connection or is losing connection
so this would I I'm envisioning that
this could be used by big organizations
that have lots of resources but it could
also be used by small nonprofits that
are trying to go into a country where
they said that the internet access isn't
good and users might have very old
smartphones so it just needs to be
really light weight and work offline as
much as possible you know so user could
take quizzes and do stuff offline as
soon as they get any type of connection
it'll send the data that's that's my
thought I'd like the UI to be
you know kind of really modern think
like Udacity is UI or something like
that
Udacity use UI is built with react and
it looks really nice I like it is it
perfect no I mean it's not perfect but
yeah I'm kind of thinking along those
lines if anybody's interested in a
project like that let me know that
doesn't have to be a project that we do
but I just thought you know I throw that
idea out there I know we talked about it
in the past but if you're it if anyone's
interested in that I can't create a repo
for it just using probably just use
create react app and just start working
on it guys so I took a long time to
explain that let me try to get through
alright I'm almost all the way through
the live chat so let me get through that
and then we'll see how much time I have
left and in terms of getting the rest of
this stuff merged
no life says on how I want to know why
the name under the quote isn't the same
like in the example I'd have to take
more of a closer look at it oh oh sauce
old sauce says what is this lotion
digitalocean is a it's like a web host
so you can purchase they call them
droplet droplets
they're like little servers okay and you
can host whatever you want on there so
usually like they run some version of
Linux so you have your own kind of Linux
machine there to do whatever you want
with when we use it to host a lot of our
websites actually if anyone is
interested in digitalocean
I can give you my code if you want and I
think you will get some free credit for
digitalocean and I will get free credit
I know there are other codes out there
that'll get you more free credit so you
don't have to use my code but if
anyone's issue let me know send it to
you I mean if I'm going to start hosting
this disk or form it would be cool to
have some X somewhere free credit
Michael criolla us is early stars in it
yeah for sure it's definitely an early
start this won't be the normal time I'm
not normally going to start at 10 a.m.
my time
Chris Amir asks about the github dark
theme okay rook said he uses github dark
first result when you google when you
google it yeah that's exactly right
thanks root
rook says do you have white space on the
right on this project on my machine I
have a horizontal scrollbar in some
empty space on the right side that's
entirely possible that we have something
like that happening
let me see oh yeah for sure what do we
have
Oh up here so yeah yeah we've really
been in my I mean I I've been ignoring
the the mobile view and like I said I
don't know what I was thinking this is
obviously a project that needs to be
made primarily with mobile view in mind
alright doctrine says I'm totally
interested we can do free projects we
can do X projects I mean like experience
projects I'm not sure with the expertise
of radiating his experience we can do
group freelance important part is having
someone experienced as a lead we could
meet on a few a week online Gander
census I would be interested in side
projects could start with nonprofits but
it could be a good move get paid at some
point a future a lot more complexity and
paid yeah I mean I'm okay with the paid
thing as well so I did I did do
freelancing in the past I'm familiar
with the contracts and billing and all
that I I have been involved with having
partners on freelance so I I do that I
mean I obviously have experience with
having projects with multiple volunteer
contributors and in that so yeah so I'd
be open to it if we were going to do it
like I said I think it would be cool to
start with some nonprofit stuff a little
bit less pressure or maybe just some
like side projects that are ideas for us
maybe the less the least amount of
pressure just to kind of get a feel for
working with each other and then after
that point we could do some some
projects that might be good because then
we actually have projects to show like
as our portfolio if we were going to do
that I want to make sure that we get
like solid clients who can afford to pay
us what we're worth right I don't I
don't want you all getting paid nothing
you know good projects right so we'll be
able to use the technology that we want
so I'm ok with that
I dunno I know some other coders I know
some people that can help us with the
business end of things as well in terms
of like handling taxes and payroll and
all that if we wanted to I don't know if
it should be based primarily like in the
United States and everything goes out we
could try to see like what's the
the best way to set that up but I think
about it yeah well um cool Blake says
I'd be interested in coordinating the
business side of things okay cool
let's alright let's do this so first
thing is let's just get together instead
of talking about things and not worry
about the the business side right away I
don't think it'd be a good idea to just
jump right into paying projects without
having worked with each other at all
old sauce is interested nick is
interested about to finish Flatiron
bootcamping looking to keep it free
advice my skills cool Nick my wife just
finished a flat iron boot camp and she
might enroll in another one of their
boot camps soon as well let's see
Baccarin says react with rails back-end
sounds like a good start okay cool yeah
I don't have any experience at all with
rails but I'm open to it
Lee says Louie's sorry from pronounce
aces lose Lu eyes II feel I see a frat
loot this is it just Louis anyway let me
know how to pronounce it I'm gonna stop
messing it up I apologize but anyway
they're interested in as well and it
says Jesse do you have any course on
udemy for example on a full development
system using react node you know all
that stuff um I don't have any courses I
don't know if anybody honestly thinks
that I should do a course let me know
I'd be interested in doing that it'd
probably take me a lot to get it
together but I really I never really
thought about doing it that question
could you explain what you're teaching I
was watching for two days but I can't
understand okay yeah it's probably been
a bit confusing for the last couple of
days because we
jumping into like different projects and
things right in the middle of it
so mostly so what I do on this stream is
i stream my day-to-day work as a
front-end developer I work for a small
University and so whatever I need to be
working on that day that's what I stream
so it's not exactly tutorial and it's
not always in in order I jump around for
project projects sometimes some
emergency thing comes up that I need to
fix but when I am streaming I try to
explain what I'm doing as best I can
in particular right now most of our
projects are JavaScript based we're
using react and the design of it is
usually based on material design and if
you have any questions about anything
let me know more than happy to explain
what I'm doing go back over something so
let me know and I'll try to help help
you understand as much as possible but
that's kind of like the short version of
what we do here all right
Harshit hat now has HTTP up and working
for javascript AF well rook says the
white space is there even when it's full
screen let's check that out
all right so you're right we do have a
bit of white space so somewhere I have
something producing some white space off
to fix that I'll off hand I don't know
what it could be but I'm sure once I
start if I check it on dev tools it
shouldn't be too hard to find
doctor says let's see if this going how
do I get in touch with you probably the
best way dacron if you're on twitter
just DM me on Twitter you can email me
at Jesse waggle gmail.com if you want to
but I like kind of prefer Twitter DM z--
once we get into like maybe more like
business whatever you need to talk more
email or something else might be better
but those two days are probably going to
be the easiest ways to talk to me
Michael Chris's wait what did I miss are
you getting paid what you stream now not
yet Michael not yet maybe one day if we
were to do a project especially if it
was paid the streams would move to
probably my channel and we may not be
able to do public streams if it's our
own side projects I'm totally fine with
us doing everything public but if it's
for a paying client we definitely have
to get them to agree to it first and I
wouldn't want to do it on free code camp
because free code camp does work kind of
exclusively with volunteer stuff for
nonprofits I could check with Quincy and
see what he thinks
but just to be safe I'm saying now that
those streams would probably have to be
on on my channel doctrine says I don't
care about pay at the moment I'm just
saying it for a learning experience and
becoming a better developer that's cool
school is
see Harsha says now you can ask
questions on discourse so that I will be
personally answering them alright cool
so hard she'll be answering questions on
this course I'm gonna check in on
discourse too and I can answer stuff
anything backend related for sure I
think harsh it's better to ask questions
about but I'm also gonna be there to
answer questions Louise okay is that how
it's pronounced Louise all right Thank
You Fabio sorry I was mispronouncing
that let's see Christ centered EV says
any time I inquire about the beta
curriculum seems like people ignore the
issue it'll be awesome if someone would
do an update since Quincy inform people
about the Xmas due date yes so I don't I
don't know for sure what happened with
the Christmas dates I never like really
looked into that so I personally have no
I have the same amount information as
you all have in terms of when the beta
curriculum is going to be out so I'm not
involved in that project so I don't know
why you're not getting an answer to the
issue I think you can work on a beta
curriculum if you want to so it is
available trying to think you would
usually anytime anyone ask Quincy the
answer is always soon so I don't I think
you probably get the same answer which
is soon which is true I mean it's Quincy
wants it to be good before it's released
and you can't really put a date on that
but I know I don't know how but I know
it's possible to start knowing the
curriculum now even though it's it's not
officially like release yet does anybody
know how to do that alright Blake's it
gotta go watch the rest later see you
later Blake thanks for watching Michael
says
if you'll take me I'm in I'm trying to
build up a CV and anything would help
okay cool for sure John Hanson said your
wife is soon going to be getting a dev
job at Google yeah I was joking I like
my wife I had joke with my wife earlier
and said she's gonna end up being my
boss one day she's gonna be a project
manager or something and but it's crazy
she's she's been working so hard and
learning so much
Andrews interested in what as well
awesome let's see a harsh said I put
your face in the logo oh I am my face is
there now let's see John Hanson said
usually that whitespace is a margin or
overflow issue yeah I often show usually
when I have white space issues I just go
into dev tools which that's that's great
is too big whoops
and I just go through and see like which
box goes over into that white space and
sometimes that'll do it it doesn't
always work I assumed it would be
something here with the header layout
they were is that it no it's not it I'm
not gonna have time to go through all
this because then I won't be able to
finish the live chat but this is like my
my normal method of troubleshooting
stuff like this usually I can find it
it was a button I thought it would be
that about this I don't know we'll see
no life says I don't understand most of
the time because I'm a newbie but I know
you definitely should make some courses
do you have some personal channel or
only air free code camp I do have a
personal channel so if you look in the
description for this video there should
be a link from my personal YouTube
channel I only have a few videos on
there now but I really would like to put
some more tutorials and hopefully I
started to put out some more videos
recently maybe I'd like to stick to like
one a week so if I could try to make a
new video once a week I think that would
be fine maybe just some short really
focused tutorials I think my channel is
just Jesse or Weigel I should just look
it up with thanks I have it here I'll
paste the link in for you all
oh it's Jesse like a twenty nine company
alright there we are so I pasted the
link to my youtube channel oh okay sorry
Brooke
so the name is Sony key so I was saying
Nicki I'm realize for that it's Nicki is
that correct Nicki off to do I'll really
try to remember that I'm sorry in the
United States lifts how we always
pronounce it so I apologize no life says
sorry for my English oh don't worry
about it your English is great
okay so rook says beta free code camp
org rook would you prefer on the streams
if I say Nicki or if I just say rook
because it doesn't matter to me either
way but I'd rather call you what you
like to be called our Andrew said Quincy
said they're still cleaning it up no
release date yet Louise says thanks for
the answer no problem in pronunciation
it's a Brazilian name
I suggest you creating a udemy course on
developing some system from scratch it
would be great all right cool I'll
definitely think about that I'll look
into like the process I'd have to go
through to do that let's see so but yeah
beta dot free code camp tour check that
out for the beta curriculum Michael says
today's a live chat is kind of cool it's
almost a group chat yeah it is it is so
I apologize for anybody to tune in the
stream that was expecting something a
little different it just kind of turned
into a chat like this which I mean it's
fine honestly we sometimes we just don't
stick to the topic I mean that's that's
how it is I guess we need to do some
something live like this but I think
this was a
a definitely good chat brooke says yep
that's right but pronouncing it the
American Way is also fine I just wanted
hear you say ah no rogue for sure I'll
pronounce it the way that you prefer to
pronounce it I'm yeah I don't want to
mispronounce your name also it works is
I have I don't have a preference in you
sing my real nickname alright maybe I'm
gonna try to say your real name and then
that way for me I like I'd like to
remember it so if I keep saying it I'll
remember it so if it's cool with you
I'll try to say it so from now on when I
see rook I'm gonna say Nikki and
hopefully there won't be too much
confusion with people in the live chat
on he'll said I'm back I see I lost a
lot of fun I guess so yeah
glad you're back though no life says
thanks I will look at it after I get a
little better so I can fully understand
that let's see Brooks's or I was already
read that one I should Irish this is
thinking for a new blog post any ideas
spooks is hyoe you creating a tribute
page for free code camp challenge no I'm
not creating a tribute page but when
we're kind of reviewing someone else's
tribute page and actually alright I
gotta wrap things up because I need to
leave like right now so I can get to my
appointment on time so thank you all so
much for I was like just just talking
with me in this dream today it was
awesome I mean we did get some things
merged in sorry we didn't get back to
fixing the merge conflicts if anyone
really wants to know about this maybe I
can do a video about it or something
maybe maybe I'll try to do it later and
just record it and I'll throw it on my
channel now we'll see let me know if
you're interested in that but anyway
I'll be back tomorrow
and I don't know what we'll be working
on tomorrow we'll see but thanks again
and until tomorrow have a great day